so essentially a comedian here in
Montreal mike Ward me to talk about a
disabled kid named [ __ ] Jimmy and after
that joke happened the kid claimed that
he was discriminated against that he was
bullied and therefore wanted to press
charges and he's won his case so first
for the viewer the after would know what
the joke is
the joke is essentially this Mike was
talking about a kid named pudgy Amy who
is who has a disability
Chester Collins the visiting me his
biggest wish was to he sang in front of
the Pope and people thought it was
terrible so they were going after him
and Mike basically defended him when
everyone was critiquing the TV me
because he's like no this guy's dying we
should protect him give him his right
it's a beautiful little wish let him
have it after that he got to sing in
front of the montreal canadiens which is
a big hockey team in Canada and people
critiqued him there Mike's offended him
know this guy's dying we should protect
him get him was right it's a beautiful
little wish let him have it then he sang
in front of Celine Dion people
criticized see Jamie again Mike defended
him no this guy's dying we should
protect him Tim is right it's beautiful
to wish I wouldn't have it then five
years passed and Mike's like yo this
little [ __ ] still alive how come he
won't die the whole social contract was
that I defend you and you die and you
did it and then I try to kill you myself
and you wouldn't drown so I was confused
I'm like this kids invincible I looked
up what his disease was turns out it's
not terminal it just makes him ugly but
the bigger picture of that the bigger
context of that job was to joke about
people that are untouchable yes that you
couldn't joke about in that whole
segment
he doesn't just laugh about a kid he
laughs about a kid he lacks about people
that are untouchable like Celine Dion at
a manager Angelia
all the people that are untouchable he's
going at them now here's even the
crazier part the joke wasn't done on
television it was done at a show where
the kid wasn't present somebody filmed
the joke then put it online journalist
stupid joke fretted the footage his dad
choked and put it online and just just
chill them yeah and so essentially
because of this joke with the tribunal
found was that his joke about the
position to me weren't hate speech but
they were discriminatory because they
made fun of him on the basis of his
disability
problem here is maybe this is just my
opinion but if you're making fun of
celebrities on the basis of their
appearance if you're making fun of all
the other celebrities but you don't make
fun of that one it would be
discriminatory to not make fun of the
specific celebrity just because he's
disabled I would argue that it's
actually inclusive to mock the disabled
person because they're treating there
like every other famous person there we
do stand-up comedy shows we have people
from all kinds of backgrounds even
people who have disabilities well
comments you'll be scared so many fun of
people in the crowd but I want Universal
and I'm like I just want to see you how
would you react like you see me this
year someone was [ __ ] different
[ __ ] up face don't make one joke not
one joke and you go talk to a lady
just near me what the hell just us worse
then just consulting me thank you one
guy like we were at comedy showcase he
took a picture anything yep my friend
wanted to to you know and my friend was
holding me and we're all okay when it
took the photo
he asked me full-time are you sure I can
pause this have a circuit for this are
you sure are you sure I'm gonna bow as
it once I was happy one you're taking a
photo chill down could be scared oh you
must you me I'm just I don't want to
fight people know what you gotta do
let's make some dough a lot of these
tribunals a lot of these Human Rights
Commission's are shams they are parallel
courts we don't have to be held to the
same high high standard of regular
criminals what ends up happening is a
lot of these courts can almost come out
as predatorial what comes happening is
that even if you win you still lose
basically the court alleged that Levent
and the Westar standard were guilty of
illegal discrimination for republishing
the Danish cartoons of the Prophet
Mohammed in 2006 a fairly long and
drawn-out legal battle battle spanning
over two years and 100,000 dollars in
fees the Alberta Human Rights Commission
dismissed the two complaints filed
against the company unfortunately by the
time they dismissed the complaints the
company went under
they couldn't afford to keep up with the
legal battle and their business all
these shut down their business shut down
their business they won what ends up
happening is a lot of these courts can
almost come out as predatorial even if
you win that case you still dished out
$200,000 even if you win you still lose
nobody even if you say that the joke is
not funny that's to you that's objective
to you and that's not what it's about
whether the joke is funny or not it
doesn't matter it's to you right Amy
Schumer special style Netflix even if I
think it's absolute garbage there's a
lot of people were like oh I like
dumpster fires and they keep watching
her stuff I understand that comedy is
subjective what's funny to you doesn't
necessarily have to be funny to other
people comedy is its own thing we're
within that realm where when we're in
there we understand that we're taking
serious topic so we're making light of
them but that's what that space is for
and then afterwards when you're outside
in the real world you can go about
saying that these things are the most
serious things in the world but when
you're at a show and someone makes 9/11
joke they're not saying terrorism is
great they're not saying correct the two
twin towers are gone what they're
essentially doing is they're trying to
find humor and something that is dark
that doesn't always come out the way
that you want it doesn't have to but you
have to understand good jokes and bad
jokes they come from the same place
they're birth from this place where I
want something to be funny but I don't
know where it's gonna go okay so when
you sit down you'd be like well that
joke wasn't funny and it was mean we
don't know it before we deliver it
because one crowd could find it funny
and the next crowd may not
yeah but that's all what's meant to be
mean know that joke was meant to talk
about the people that we cannot touch
you see you have to take the bigger
picture here which you're not doing
you're taking it out of a context which
is not doing it justice to me it's like
evidence that this whole political
correctness of social justice for any
types I've really infiltrated a lot of
the upper lash loves their ideology is
really infiltrate these places because
I'm just saying this is crazy
we're suing someone over jokes but no
it's just a few people you realize that
if Mike loses this case his point about
Liberty Jaime being untouchable it's
right he's right he made its point
because he touched that kid and he was
in touchable and now yes well he didn't
literally touch that controller back
yeah yeah roll it back and I don't think
anybody wants to touch that kid
we have to make something clear we are
theory on what comedy should look like
what fun is irrelevant this is not about
what you think because there is no one
way to do comedy
there's safe space comedy there's LGBTQ
comedy there's racial comedy there's all
forms of different than there's
offensive there's dark there's all forms
of comedy and what we love is the fact
that there's a variety of it even if I
wouldn't entertain most of it I do
appreciate the fact that such variety
because there's something for each
audience and when you try to impose your
brand on everybody else your set of
standards on everybody else you are
incent inherently stifling free speech
you're saying that my way is
compassionate and that yours isn't when
they're arguing that their way is
compassionate and that yours is it well
you're not free from consequence listen
to somebody's effect that you are
stifling free speech and yes we do have
certain ways in which we stifle free
speech but they're very peculiar ways
with very peculiar instances this is far
reaching and far more devastating than
you realize and your face jokes
if jokes can be the measure by which
we're gonna start soon people then that
is well now we've crossed the line
that's quite huntress yeah there's a
difference between you saying the joke
about somebody and you going in a
theater and yelling fire yes that's
illegal and it should be illegal but me
telling a joke there's a context if
context is very important in this yeah
you do not take the joke out of its
context um it makes no sense no you know
the worst part about it is like Mike
could afford to pay off to find no
problem with one of his life the reason
why he's not doing it is he doesn't want
to set a legal precedent that says that
because you're jokingly saying these
things you deserve to pay a fine that a
lot of people can't pay so then you
deserve to go to jail so he's fighting
the case and so other people don't have
to suffer that I think you know people
don't recognize how important that is
it's not funny so anyway leave your
comments below you know we wanna know
what you guys think
[Music]
oh my question I've done the joke or he
went too far no I didn't want to fall
that's comedy that's comedy guys I'm
where else to back him let's make some
money
yeah if Mike would make a joke about me
and keep touring I'm like all right I
want to make a joke about you record it
and put it on YouTube
let's go make some money I don't care
just I don't not to say anything
otherwise just the comments are not
telling me I secure personal there's
ignorant idiots idiots you just give
them a platform to say I'm a victim let
them speak and let them see I know them
doesn't know what to go don't you see
I'm no [ __ ] no just let them be in your
demand do what you gotta do
quick announcement we're gonna be
starting up quite a few changes for the
new year
this Friday we're gonna be doing a live
stream here on YouTube where we're gonna
be discussing some of the videos that we
did this week as well some of your
comments so if you want to leave some
feedback if you want to yell at us
that's your place to do it so be sure to
check in for that as well in the new
year we're gonna be switching things up
because we all want to diversify our
income but we also want to make more
projects we're gonna be really pushing
our patreon what that means is that
we're going to have a live podcast that
is going to be exclusive to our patreon
people if you suggest topics give us
questions there's going to be tears that
are gonna be set up in order to reward
you for the fact that you want to have
your input put into the channel so be
sure to check that out we're also gonna
have exclusive clips that we put out
once a week on the patreon so if you
want extra content if you want to
support us and really help us to do this
full-time
then that's a way you can do it